ممكن ان تقع كارثه صحيه
وتلوث وقد وقد وقعت هذه الكارثه يعني بعض
الناس الان موجود لديه عده امراض احنا
بنعاني هالحين من مشكله حاده في اللي هي
النفات الطبيه والنظافه في سواء كان داخل
الاقسام او خارج الاقسام ويرجع ذلك لعده
اسباب يعني منها اولا يعني عدم توفر
المعدات اللازمه وادوات النظافه على سبيل
المثال يعني ما فيش عنا حين لا يتوفر
لدينا اللي هو قشطات مكانس مواد نظافه
صابون ايدي صابون الارضيات مطهر ارضيات
كلور ماء
النار كان في السابق يتم فرز النتيات من
قبل الكوادر الطبيه عننا كيس اسود
للنفايات العاديه والكيس الاصفر للنفايات
الموجيه يتم نقل وجمع النفايات في داخل
الاقسام نفسها من ضمن حاويات كبيره ثم يتم
الزود بها الى مكب النفايات
وكانت كانت الامور تمشي على وثيره سليمه
لكن الامور اصبحت صعبه جدا لدرجه انه
احيانا ان الحاويات التي تتم والموجوده في
مركبه النفات اصبحت تنقل في داخل الاقسام
وهذا اكبر
خطا من جهه ثانيه اللي هو العدد الكبير من
المرضى والنازحين ففي المستشفى اليوم يعني
يزيد عن 30,000 ما بين مريض ونازح اضافه
الى وجود النازحين في مراكز الاواء ال
مجاوره للمستشفى حيث يترددون على المستشفى
للاستفاده من الخدمات وهذا يؤثر على
المخرجات وعلى النفايات وزياده
حجمها احنا عننا في اشكاليه كبيره انه عدم
توفر مواد ومعدات نظافه بسبب استيرادها من
الشمال للجنوب والقطع والطرق متقطعه
بنعاني كثير من الشيء هذا العمال بقوم
يقومون تجميع النفايات من الاقسام الى
اماكن تجميع النفايات في الخلف المستشفى
طبعا هذا يشكل خطوره على بذات المرضى
المنقص المناعه لانه المرضى المنقص
المناعه سواء الاطفال او في مرضى عندهم
الامراض المزمنه مرضى السكر مرضى الضغط كل
هؤلاء م نطلق عليهم كبار السن مرض مقصين
المناعه لا يتحملوا مثل هذا
الوضع سيارات اللي هي ترحيل النفايات من
المستشفى الى المكاب يعني عدم انتظام
حضورهم بسبب اللي هو يعني اللي هو الحرب
الموجوده فاحيانا
يتعرض السائقين هؤلاء الشاحنات او العربات
المخصص لترحيل النفات لاطلاق النار للقصف
وكذلك المكب نفسه تعرض للقصف وهذا يؤدي
انه تاخر ترحيل
[موسيقى]
النفايات هناك طبعا مخاطر شديده وهي مخاطر
انتقال العدوى وذلك بسبب العبث من قبل
الاطفال في النفايات الطبيه الموجوده
والمتراكم في جميع انحاء المستشفى والتي
يمكن ان يؤدي الى امراض معديه تنتقل عن
طريق اللي هو الجروح او اما عن طريق
التلامس لهذه النفايات او عن طريق
الاستنشاق اضطرينا ان نتعامل بانفسنا و
بالمتطوعين حتى نستطيع ان نسيطر رغم وجود
ازمات كثيره لحتى اللحظه لم تحل لم تحل
ونحن
نحاول